and the truth is that I had to face him
to have to face him to achieve
the goal that we have to mean
at 168 pounds but we have this
fight in May with billie joe
saunders, a great fighter and you can
continue to
connect the belts at 168
pounds
canarias and xàtiva
gardner buttons expansion of voters in
islantilla scale like voldemort gold
rush me
and to be champion already that champions for the
w
is a union of scope where you can
discover in age
stern and faith is not the typical friend
too much way up
has a good  system
the night feel good eye there are films
there are moments there is finlay that in my bar and
can't beat beat
wifi in eibar and in and variation to fight
la davis fire laude
billie joe saunders good from time to
time
goodbye fight in december
las december ipad  with the number one in
one sixty they live in it
we were great detective mike witt
channel server for maximum tv and also in
ate week statistics ine
barberá live united  fee to have
state administrations
no obviously I am making my
investments I have many projects outside
of boxing I right now of God with my
investments I could retire from boxing
and I continue living my life that I
live today but I love what I do boxing and
I will give it up  that until my
body can no longer be banal and
boyfriends the earthquake the value of the other
manifestations mónica my project and the
queens john buck without haste and not the same
this one is going well for investment in
resistance
donald no federations the one for
priori reigns is  life this is for
boxing
and they know barren
and when the cb comes out
if this
to haiti
heavyweight
byrs
the street
and
[Music]